foreign
foreign
distinguished delegates ladies and
gentlemen
it gives me great pleasure to declare
open the 27th session of the conference
of the parties to the United Nations
framework convention on climate change
friends let me Begin by thanking our
friends here in Egypt for such a warm
welcome
my team and I know just how demanding
hosting such a conference is and how
many people have worked incredibly hard
to get us to this point
so congratulations and thank you again
now as the UK's presidency comes to an
end
I want to reflect
on what we achieved together
in Glasgow
and also what has happened since in our
presence a year
last November the world gathered at [ __ ]
26 against a fractured and fractious
geopolitics as a once in a century
pandemic dragged mercilessly on
and yet
leaders recognize that despite their
differences
often profound
cooperation on climate and nature is in
our Collective self-interest
thanks that Spirit of cooperation and
compromise we forged together the
Glasgow climate Pact
collectively
we achieved something historic
and something hopeful
with your help we close the Paris rule
book we made unprecedented progress on
coal and on fossil fuel subsidies
we committed to rapidly scale up finance
and to double adaptation Finance by 2025
we reiterated the urgency of action and
support for loss and damage and
established serious work on funding
Arrangements
and we hope
that that is paved the way for a formal
agenda item and tangible progress here
in Egypt and every everybody and I
repeat this every party agreed to
revisit and strengthen their 2030
emission reduction targets to align with
Paris
so I want to thank the 29 countries
which have already updated their ndcs
since Glasgow
from Australia to Micronesia India to
Vanuatu Norway to Gabon
and we also made progress outside the
negotiating rooms with commitments from
business from Finance from philanthropy
friends
thanks to the work that we did together
we achieved our objective the goal at
the heart of the Paris agreement we kept
1.5 degrees alive
now none of us could have anticipated
the year that followed
we have been buffeted by global
headwinds that have tested our ability
to make progress
Putin's brutal and illegal war in
Ukraine has precipitated multiple Global
crisis energy and food insecurity
inflationary pressures and spiraling
debt
and these crisis
have compounded existing climate
vulnerabilities and the scarring effects
of the pandemic
and yet
despite this context there has been some
progress in implementing the commitments
that we delivered in Glasgow
over 90 percent of the global economy is
now covered by NetZero Target up from
less than 30 percent when the UK took on
the cop 26th role
the biggest companies
and the financial institutions the world
have committed to Net Zero they've done
so in force
with a global wall of capital creating
green jobs and directing billions into
the green industries of both today and
tomorrow
countries and companies are making
tangible sexual progress from zero
emission vehicles to our breakthrough
agenda and are accelerating the rollout
of renewable energy across the world
and the Secretary General
has been clear
our shared long-term Futures do not lie
in fossil fuels
and I agree with him wholeheartedly
if
every major report published this year
underscores the point that progress is
being made
and thanks to the commitments that we
garnered a head off and at cop26 and
indeed in our presidency year emissions
in 2030 are expected to be around six
gigatons lower
that is the equivalent of 12 of today's
Global annual emissions
and with full implementation of all the
commitments in place today including
ndc's and Net Zero targets the reports
suggest that we're heading to 1.7
degrees warming by the end of the
century
not 1.5
but still
progress
so to those who remain skeptical
about the multilateral process
and of the [ __ ] process in particular
my message is clear
as unwieldy and sometimes as frustrating
as these processes can be the system is
delivering
and there are many people to thank for
that and certainly too many to name
the prime ministers and the presidents
who have sensed the changing wind and
indeed sought instead to harness it
the ministers to the miners who have
recognized a just and sustainable future
can only be delivered with a clean
energy transition
the Civil Society organizations youth
representatives and Indigenous peoples
who pushed us to consider and reconsider
what was possible in Glasgow have
continued to do so since
and of course
the brilliant officials the brilliant
civil servants around the world not
least in the UK's cop unit who have
helped to deliver progress
and yet
despite this progress
I fully recognize the scale of the
challenge still in front of us
just as every report shows that we are
making some progress
they're equally clear that there is so
much more to be done in this critical
decade
friends we are not currently on a
pathway that keeps 1.5 in reach
and whilst I do understand that leaders
around the world have faced competing
priorities this year we must be clear as
challenging as our current moment is
inaction is myopic and can only defer
climate catastrophe
we must find the ability to focus on
more than one thing at once
how many more wake-up calls does the
world do world leaders actually need
third of Pakistan underwater the worst
flooding in Nigeria in a decade this
year the worst drought in 500 years in
Europe in a thousand years in the U.S
and the worst on record in China the
cascading risks are also clear
entire economic sectors becoming
unsustainable and uninsurable entire
regions becoming unlivable and the
strain on the global movement of goods
and the pressure of people to relocate
because the climate crisis becoming
almost unimaginable
so this conference must be about
concrete action
and I hope that when the world leaders
join us today they will explain clearly
what their countries have achieved
during the last year and how they will
go further
it is very simply a matter of trust
without its constituent members
delivering on their commitments and
agreeing to go further the entire system
falters
I will do everything in my power to
support our Egyptian friends and the UK
is here to reach ambitious outcomes
across the agenda including on
mitigation on adaptation and loss and
damage
and we know
that we have reached a point where
Finance makes or breaks the program of
work that we had ahead of us
so whilst I would point to some of the
progress shown on the 100 billion
dollars I hear the criticisms and I
agree that more must be done by
governments and by the multilateral
development Banks including on doubling
it adaptation Finance by 2025 and
establishing a post-2025 goal
ultimately though
I remain hopeful
look back to where we were before
Glasgow
look back to where we were before Paris
indeed as we Mark the 30th Anniversary
look back to where we were before Rio
with thanks to all of you
the UK's presidency ends as a
demonstration that progress is possible
it is happening and it is continuing
yes we need to accelerate that progress
and the remainder of the decisive decade
but I believe fundamentally that we can
we know what we need to do to keep 1.5
degrees alive we know how to do it
and Sami you and your team have our full
support
so now friends
let's make sure we deliver let's make it
happen thank you
[Applause]
so distinguished delegates
I would like to invite you to turn to
sub item 2A of the provisional agenda
for the session
titled election of the president of the
conference of the parties at its 27th
session
you may recall
that in accordance with rule 22
paragraph one of the Draft rules of
procedure being applied the Office of
the President of the conference of
parties is subject to rotation amongst
the five Regional groups
we now continue the cycle
with a president from the African States
so it gives me great pleasure
to propose that the conference elect
by acclimation his Excellency Mr Sami
shukri who will serve as president of
the conference at its 27th session
[Applause]
I therefore declare his Excellency Mr
samishukri elected president of the 27th
session of the conference of the parties
[Music]
I congratulate Mr shukri on this
election and wish him and his team every
success in guiding the work of the
conference I'll now invite Mr shukri to
take his seat at the podium welcome Mr
President
[Applause]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
thank you
foreign
foreign
foreign
thank you
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
Paris
foreign
foreign
foreign
say that was said
and anyways
foreign
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
[Applause]
guests colleagues
this morning we are honored to have with
us Mr hosang Lee chair of the
intergovernmental panel on climate
change and Mr Simon Steele UNF Triple C
executive secretary
there's now my pleasure to invite Mr
Simon Steele
UNF Triple C executive secretary to
address the plenary
honorable guests
distinguished delegates ladies and
gentlemen I'm delighted to welcome you
officially to cop 27.
salaam alaikum
I must thank my predecessor
Patricia Espinoza
we're all grateful for the valuable work
you did over the last six years
thank you to the outgoing cop president
Alec Sharma and his able team for their
leadership over the last three years
and I'd like to officially congratulate
the Egyptian presidency and Minister
shukri for his election
thank you for your tireless efforts as
we work to make cop 27 a success
friends
today a new era begins and we begin to
do things differently
Paris gave us the agreement katowice and
Glasgow gave us the plan
shifts us to implementation
no one can be a mere passenger on this
journey
this is a signal that times have changed
as executive secretary of the UN climate
convention it is an honor to be standing
in a room of people dedicated to
tackling Humanity's greatest challenge
every one of you brings a unique
perspective
I come from Grenada
a state of three islands of karaku and
pitty Martinique
karaku is my home he where my family
lived on a 13 square mile island with a
population of just seven thousand people
our history is of seafarers fishes boat
builders
Farmers surviving on their wits and the
strength of their communities working
closely together
my roots lie in a life full of beauty
and adversity
as a teenager I became involved in the
global issues of the day
the proliferation of nuclear weapons and
the anti-apartheid movement
I joined demonstrations and protests
I was often told one person cannot make
a difference well
Nelson Mandela said it always seems
impossible until it is done
I hold that thought close to me it
always seems impossible until it is done
so this is why I say today a new era
begins and we begin to do things
differently
we will be holding people to account
be they presidents Prime Ministers or
CEOs an accountability Chief if you may
because our policies our businesses our
infrastructure our actions be they
personal or public must be aligned with
the Paris agreement and with the
convention
the heart of implementation is everybody
everywhere in the world
every single day doing everything they
possibly can to address the climate
crisis
there are those that are going forward
further and faster than everyone else
these are examples that must be followed
there are those who just need a nudge
into taking further action to go beyond
business as usual
there are others who need support so
they are able to do the things they need
to do for their countries and
communities specifically highly
vulnerable Nations
and then there are those who still
refuse to act unless others do
they will not be allowed to slow down
the collective process let's not let
positioning block progress
all of us have to do everything we are
capable of doing
and we have that opportunity over the
next two weeks
our cop process is unique
we must create a safe political space
shielded from whatever else is going on
out there
to do our jobs and deliver World change
the geopolitical situation the pandemic
the food and energy crisis have hit
countries economies and most importantly
individuals hard
but let me make this point to humbly
remind all of those engaged in this
process of a simple fact
for decades communities all over the
world very often the most vulnerable
people have been dealing with the
continuous stream of crises facing
impact of the impact of climate change
this is strict generations of their
lives and livelihoods
so here in charmele Sheikh we have a
duty to speed up our International
efforts to turn words into action to
catch up with their lived experience
this is a party driven process over the
course of my term I will be mobilizing
the process and Secretariat to boost
parties Drive
this is my promise to you
I want you to focus on three
critical lines of action
this is what I want you to deliver on
first we must demonstrate this
transformational shift to implementation
but in negotiations into concrete
actions
every corner of human activity must
align with our Paris commitment of
pursuing efforts to limit temperature
rise to 1.5 degrees
let's be encouraged by the strides that
certain sectors are making on this and
let's look closer at how the Global
Financial architecture can be made fit
for purpose in line with the Paris
commitments
the second line of action we must cement
progress on these critical extremes
mitigation
adaptation finance and crucially loss
and damage
we need to enable enhanced Finance to
flow to addressing impacts
what is said in these negotiating rooms
has to be reflected
in the urgency of what is happening
outside
there are areas of commonality which we
can lean into and build Bridges upon we
must build those bridges
at this cop session some process will
find themselves at a Midway point
others will be initiated and there are
some that will have to be Revisited
finally our third line of action we must
enhance the delivery of the principles
of transparency and accountability
throughout the process
the environmental integrity and the
reliability of the commitments made are
Paramount
I welcome detailed plans on how we
deliver what we have promised across
Finance adaptation and mitigation
I found myself in my accountability
Chief role last week when we launched
the NDC synthesis report and I had to
report that only 29 countries had come
forward with tightened National plans
since cop 26.
29 is not 194.
so here I am now looking out at 165
countries that are due to be revisiting
and strengthening their National pledges
this year
I want to take a moment now to recognize
the Glasgow climate Pact
we made this agreement together only
last year
I am not in a habit of rescinding on my
word I firmly expect all parties to act
the same way
stick to your commitments
build on them here in Egypt I will not
be a custodian of backsliding
as the world pivots to implementation
women and girls have to be placed at the
center of climate decision making and
action
[Applause]
Fair empowerment leads to better
governance and better and better
outcomes and we need that
this formal process is led by Parties by
party States
but it is permanently inspired
challenged and pressed into action by
Civil Society organizations who not only
Advocate but act on the strength of
their convictions I intend to listen
closely to their voices particularly
those of the youth making sure they can
be clearly heard and importantly felt
[Applause]
our [ __ ] process has delivered a
remarkable transition in the
consciousness of humanity in the
timeline of human development
our minds have moved from researching to
understanding
and then to agreeing on a plan
to paraphrase the wonderful Nobel
prize-winning Egyptian writer Nagib
mafuse
you can tell whether a person is clever
by their answers you can tell whether a
person is Wise by their questions
we have demonstrated the very best in
human wisdom by asking the right
questions
now we know what must be done
by everybody
everywhere
every single day doing everything we
possibly can
colleagues
time to get to work
shukran thank you
thank you executive secretary
distinguished colleagues
the intergovernmental panel on climate
change is the United Nations body for
assessing the science related to climate
change
recognizing the continued importance of
the ipcc within the climate process as
we begin cop 27
I would like to invite Mr hosang Lee
chair of the intergovernmental panel on
climate change to address the plenary
you have the floor Mr Lee
foreign
ladies and gentlemen as the chair of the
intergovernment panel and climate change
ipcc and delighted and honored to
address you at the opening of cup 27.
we are very grateful to the Egyptian
government and the presidency of cup 27
for hosting this crucial conference
we also want to extend our thanks to the
people of charmezric for their warmest
welcome and generous Hospitality thank
you
the voice of today's science on climate
change could not be sharper
stronger and more sobering
we are not on track today to limit
global warming to 1.5 degrees Celsius
the time for our Collective action is
now
ipcc reports presented to the world in
February and April this year
clearly show that we have the technology
and the know-how to tackle climate
change
but these options are limited by the
availability of Finance among others
adaptation options are further limited
by global warming levels
with increasing warming
losses and damages will increase and
additional human and natural systems
will be pushed to adaptation limits
therefore the prerequisite to a
successful adaptation is ambitious
mitigation to keep global warming within
limits particularly 1.5 degrees Celsius
through immediate and deep Cuts in the
emissions of greenhouse gases
progress on the financial flows
comparable to the goals of Paris
agreement remains low
accelerated International Financial
cooperation is a critical enabler of low
emission and just transition
adaptation gaps especially in the
developing countries a particularly
driven by widening disparities between
the cost of adaptation and financing
available too
adaptation
we can achieve the greatest gains in
well-being by prioritizing Finance to
reduce climate risks for low-income and
marginalized communities
since the Paris agreement
many countries have put in place
climate Palos climate policies and
regulations
but their scope needs to be expanded
their ambition raised and implemented
this is a once in a generation
opportunity to save our planet and our
livelihoods
ladies and gentlemen and distinct
delegates
this is an opportunity as well as an
obligation
the range of options and most of all the
time available to them now
will not be there for Future Leaders and
policy makers
before closing
allow me to reassure you that the
scientific Community remains ready to
work with you and support you in every
step in the way
every step of the way in this journey to
limit global warming and also for
achieving sustainable development
Humanity our planet and species living
on it
deserve nothing less thank you very much
[Applause]
thank you Mr Lee the Excellence is
distinguished delegates ladies and
gentlemen
this brings us to the end of the opening
statements of cop 27
delegates please remain in your seats we
will continue with the first plenary
meeting of cop27 followed by the first
plenary meeting of the cpm17 and the
first plenary meeting of the cma4
thank you very much
distinguished delegates and I invite the
conference to consider sub item 2 b of
the provisional agenda
adoption of the rules of procedure
the Draft rules are contained in
document
F Triple C slash CP slash
1996 slash two
parties may recall that the draft's
rules of procedure are being applied
with the exception of draft rule 42 on
voting
due to lack of consensus
this has been the case since the first
session of the conference of the parties
in 1995.
at cop 26
the president held consultations and
reported that there continued to be no
consensus on the matter and proposed
that consultations continue at cop 27.
I therefore propose that we continue to
apply the Draft rules of procedure with
the exception of draft rule 42.
I would like to propose that a senior
member of my delegation holds informal
consultations on this issue
I give the floor
to Bangladesh
thank you Mr President and
congratulations on being given the
responsibility to be the president of
cop27
um it goes without saying that under
your presidency what we achieve in terms
of outcome will have an impact not only
on all people living in the world today
but also all child which is going to be
born from today onwards
um
Bangladesh is not opposing to the
adoption of the Draft rules but being
encouraged by what the executive
secretary has said that this is the cop
from where we are going to do things
differently he talked about the
importance of aligning our processes to
the convention he also talked about
accountability being enforced so the
Convention as you rightly pointed out Mr
President actually states that we are
supposed to adopt the rules in the very
first session
and the fact that we have not been able
to do so even after 26 cops and now the
27 cop
does leave a question mark as to the
commitment of all of the parties to
ensure that we have a process to
formalize the decisions that we take
now if we take out rule 42 again I say
we are not Bangladesh is not objecting
to it the onus is going to rely on you
Mr President to make a call as to how we
decide how are the decisions going to be
taken and in this regard I think the
important point to make is that by
consensus we do not mean consent of all
so consensus is actually a general
agreement a broad agreement so we hope
that certainly as we go through the
various challenges that we have and the
various agenda items consensus will not
be used to mean it's a unanimity in all
respect because that Mr President has
has been the case in the past leads to a
situation where we are going to go on
the lowest common denominator that means
whatever we agree is going to be so weak
so ineffective that it is not going to
be anywhere near to the challenges of
today and what the U.N Secretary General
referred to as a global catastrophe so
we make this point and we would like
this to be recorded we certainly think
that this is an issue which needs to be
addressed and resolved as soon as
possible but we are not objecting to the
adoption of the agenda thank you Mr
President
I thank the distinguished representative
of Bangladesh
hearing no objection to the adoption of
the rules of procedure as has been
indicated
they're so decided
let us now consider sub item 2C of the
provisional agenda adoption of the
agenda
I invite parties to turn to document F
Triple C slash CP slash
two zero two two slash one slash add two
which contains the supplementary
provisional agenda for the cop and their
revised list of agenda to be considered
under agenda item 8.
I wish to thank all parties for their
active and constructive engagement in
the Intensive consultations on the
adoption of the agendas for cop27
cpm17
and cma4
while parties expressed the range of
views there was a common desire to
initiate proceedings swiftly and
smoothly today
with the eyes of the world on Sharma
Sheikh
this sends a positive signal to the
world that parties remain committed to
addressing the global challenge of
climate change
several parties expressed concern about
the large number of agenda items
proposed by parties on top of the
workload in Sharma Sheikh
all of these issues are important
and my team and I
took great care to ensure that all views
were heard and accommodated to the
extent possible
further to the consultations undertaken
please allow me to outline the
understandings reached regarding the
adoption of the agendas of the cop and
the CMA
as they are interrelated
I will also touch on the organization of
work for some specific agenda items
based on the consultations conducted and
feedback received
by the presidency
in presenting the revised provisional
agendas
I wish to provide several clarifications
on the proposal by the g77 in China
to include an item on the agendas of the
cop and the CMA entitled matters
relating to funding arrangements for
addressing loss and damage
I propose that the agenda item title be
revised as follows
matters relating to funding Arrangements
responding to loss and damage associated
with the adverse effects of climate
change including a focus on addressing
loss and damage
with the following text
added as a footnote to the title of the
item
quote this item and the outcomes thereof
are without prejudice to the
consideration of similar issues in the
future
it is understood that
first the outcomes of this agenda item
are based on cooperation and
facilitation and do not involve
liability or compensation
second this agenda item includes the
Glasgow dialogue
and third the agenda item will launch a
process with a view to adopting a
conclusive decision no later than
2024.
on the proposal by Zambia on behalf of
the African group to include an item on
the agenda for the CMA on the special
needs and special
circumstances of Africa I propose to
convene informal consultations on the
special needs and special circumstances
of Africa and to report under the agenda
item entitled other matters
these informal consultations would
include the proposal by the African
group
and any other issues raised in the
consultations
on the proposals by France on behalf of
the European Union and Switzerland on
behalf of the environmental Integrity
group
for an item on the CMA agenda on matters
related to article 2.1 C of the Paris
agreement
I propose to convene informal
consultations on the inclusion of the
proposed agenda item matters related to
article 2.1 C of the Paris agreement on
the CMA agenda
on the proposal by Georgia for an item
on the cop agenda on Equitable
geographical representation and
constituent constituted bodies under
convention
I propose to convene informal
consultations on Equitable geographical
representation and constituted bodies
under the convention and to report under
the agenda item entitled other matters
the informal consultations would include
the proposal by Georgia the assessment
prepared by the Secretariat and any
other issues raised in the consultations
on the proposal by the United States of
America for an item on the CMA agenda on
the seventh review of the financial
mechanism I propose to convene in
informal consultations on the seventh
review of the financial mechanism
on the proposal by Switzerland on behalf
of the environmental Integrity group to
include an item on the CMA agenda on
limiting global warming to 1.5 degrees
Centigrade I propose to convene informal
consultations on the inclusion of the
proposed agenda item limiting global
warming to 1.5 degrees Centigrade
on the proposal by Pakistan on behalf of
the group of 77 and China for an item on
the cop and CMA agendas on
implementation of decisions once slash
CP
point 26 para 11 and 1 CMA 0.3 paragraph
18 on Ada
adaptation Finance I propose to convene
in informal consultations on the
inclusion of the proposed agenda item
implementation of decisions one slash CP
point 26 para 11 and one slash CMA 0.3
para 18 on adaptation Finance
further I propose that the following
items be held in abeyance
Corp item 15 consideration of proposals
from parties and amendments to the
convention under Article 15
sub item a proposal from the Russian
Federation to amend Article 4 paragraph
2 F of the convention
and sub Item B proposal from Papua New
Guinea and Mexico to amend articles 7
and 18 of the convention
cup item 16 second review of the
adequacy of article 4 paragraph 2 A and
B of the convention
dear delegates with these understandings
and with the immense gratitude for the
flexibility shown by all parties to
allow our important work to begin forth
with
I therefore proposed that the
supplementary provisional agenda as
contained in document
F Triple C slash CP slash
two zero two two slash one slash add
point two
be adopted
if there are no requests
actually sees delegates
if there are no requests
no objections
it is so decided
[Applause]
distinguished delegates regarding the
agenda item for which informal
consultations by the presidency are
required I wish to inform that I will
appoint senior members of my delegation
to leave these informal consultations
that I just outlined on my behalf and I
will keep parties informed on the
progress of the consultations
excellencies distinguished delegates
allow me once again to express our
appreciation to everyone who contributed
to the smooth and Rapid adoption of the
agenda
our success in launching our work
without delay sends an important message
of commitment to expeditiously commence
our important and Urgent work on all
items of our agenda
I particularly welcome the agreement of
the parties to include a new agenda item
on funding arrangements to respond to
loss and damage
this creates for the first time an
institutionally stable space on the
formal agenda of the cop and the Paris
agreement to discuss the pressing issue
of funding Arrangements needed to deal
with existing gaps responding to loss
and damage
[Music]
all parties contributed to forging this
consensus around the agenda through
their flexible and constructive
engagement over nearly 48 Hours of
continuous consultations led by the cop
27 presidency culminating a year of
continuous work by the presidency
but at this juncture it gives me
pleasure to express our sincere
appreciation to state Secretary Morgan
of Germany and Minister riojas of Chile
for their tireless work in bringing
parties together around this important
issue
[Applause]
the inclusion of this agenda reflects a
sense of solidarity and empathy with the
suffering of the victims of
climate-induced disasters and to this
end we all over debt of gratitude to
activists and Civil Society
organizations who have persistently
demanded the space to discuss funding
for loss and damage and thus provided
the impetus needed to bring this matter
forward
[Applause]
the conference is now invited to
consider sub item 2D of the agenda
election of offices other than the
president
and
Rasmussen vice president of the cop has
begun consultations on behalf of the cup
26th president on the election of
offices to bodies under the convention
the Kyoto Protocol and the Paris
agreement
groups have not yet completed their
consultations and nominations are still
pending
I would like to thank vice president
Anne for the work so far and I propose
that she continues the consultations to
finalize the nominations
I propose to postpone the election of
the other members of the cop 27 Bureau
until nominations are finalized and to
return to this item at the closing
plenary of the cop to conduct the
elections
in accordance with the established
practice confirmed nominees to the
bureau will be invited to attend
meetings of the bureau as observers
during the conference until the
elections have taken place
parties will note
that only nine out of the 132
nominations expected have been received
further
women currently comprise only 38 percent
of the membership of the convention
Toyota protocol and Paris agreement
bodies
I urge parties to nominate men and women
equally so that we can achieve the goal
of gender balance
I
I urge parties to intensify efforts to
conclude the remaining nominations so
that these can be transmitted by the
deadline of 8 pm on Saturday 12th of
November
if I hear no objections
it is so decided
the conference is now invited to
consider sub item 2E of the agenda
admission of organizations as Observers
the conference has before it document F
triple CP slash
2022-7
which includes a list of igos and ngos
that have expressed a wish to
participate in our work at cop27
this list was the basis on which
organizations were informed of their
pre-admitted status to cop 27 on the
understanding that final authority to
Grant admission lies with the cop
in accordance with the recommendations
of the bureau on this matter I invite
the conference to admit as observers the
organizations listed in document F
triple CP 2022-7
hearing no objection it is so decided
foreign
parties will recall that cop 25
requested the SBI to review the approach
to admitting Observer organizations and
to provide any relevant guidance to the
Secretariat
the cop may wish to know that the SBI is
56
took note of the information provided by
the Secretariat on the process of
admission of Observer organizations to
the UNF Triple C and provided no further
guidance to the Secretariat
I now invite delegates to consider sub
item 2f of the agenda organization of
work including the sessions of the
subsidiary bodies
today the governing and subsidiary
bodies will convene their opening
plenaries and launch work under all
agenda items
upon completion of the opening plenaries
of the
sbsta and SBI the five bodies will
reconvene in a joint plenary to hear
statements from groups and observer
organizations
dear colleagues let me outline how I
would like to organize work in the cop
I propose that consideration of item 4
reporting from the review of parties
including an Annex one be deferred to
cop 28.
on the following items the cop will take
appropriate action on the basis of
recommendations from the subsidiary
bodies
item 5 reporting from parties not
included in Annex one to the convention
item six report of the adoption adoption
committee for 2022
item 7 Warsaw International mechanism
for loss and damage associated with
climate change impacts
sub item A and B of item 9 development
and transfer of Technologies
item 10 capacity building under the
convention
item 11 matters related to the least
developed countries
item 12 report of a forum on the impact
of the implementation of response
measures
item 13 second periodic review review of
the long-term Global goal under the
convention and of overall progress
towards achieving it
em 14 gender and climate change
sub item A and B of item 17
administrative financial and
institutional matters
these items are already on the agendas
of the respective subsidiary body and
that body May develop draft decisions or
conclusions for consideration by the cop
as appropriate
in addition I propose to refer the
following matters to the relevant
subsidiary bodies
under agenda item 6 report of the
adoption committee for 2022.
report of the adaptation committee for
2022 I propose to refer the review of
the progress Effectiveness and
performance of the adaptation committee
to the
SB STA and SBI elections of the members
of the adaptation committee will be
taken up at the conclusion of the cop
under agenda item 14 gender and climate
change I propose to refer the
consideration of the annual report on
gender composition and this synthesis
report on progress in integrating a
gender perspective in constituent body
process to the subsidiary body
on Saturday 12th of November
the sbsta and the SBI will conclude
their work
I look forward to receiving the results
under the leadership of Mr
a penny of the subsidiary body under the
leadership of
Miss
Carlson
upon closure
I will convene a stock take meeting to
assess the status of negotiations and to
propose our way of working during the
second week of the conference
finally please note that I plan to
convene informal consultations at the
level of heads of Delegation on the
overarching decisions of the conference
for the cop
the ca
mcmp and the CMA
the consultations to be facilitated by
senior representatives of the presidency
will start in the first week and will be
concluded in the second week of the
session
I count on cooperation of all parties in
the work on these decisions which will
be notable which will be a notable part
of the overall outcomes of our work here
in Sharma Sheikh
dear colleagues tomorrow Monday the 7th
of November will be honored by the
presence of his Excellency of the fatah
CC president of the Arab Republic of
Egypt his Excellency Mr Antonio
Gutierrez Secretary General of the
United Nations and other heads of state
and government and dignitaries for the
opening ceremony of the Sharma Sheikh
climate implementation Summit
this first part of the high level
segment will also take place during the
summit on the afternoon of Monday the
7th and on Tuesday the 8th of November
where heads of state and government will
deliver their National statements or
statements on behalf of the UNF Triple C
negotiating groups
the high-level segment will then resume
on Tuesday 15th November and Wednesday
the 16th of November to continue hearing
National statements from parties whose
heads of state of government did not
speak during the first part
on Wednesday the 16th of November upon
conclusion of the national statements we
will hear statements from senior
representatives of intergovernmental
and non-governmental organizations
on Thursday 17th of November and Friday
the 18th of November the cop will
reconvene to consider the decisions and
conclusions for adoptions
I hear no objections to what has been
proposed
we will therefore proceed on this basis
it is so decided
I give the floor to the United Arab
Emirates
thank you chair
distinguished delegates climate change
is a global challenge that requires
devotion and collaboration between
countries Nations and people the unfcc
and the Paris agreement are our unique
instruments of such International
cooperation on jointly finding climate
change
for over 80 years and last eight months
Ukraine is fighting another War
Ukraine is facing unprecedented
full-scale War launched by terroristic
state of Russia against Ukraine
this immoral war in the heart of Europe
is divorce against
Ukraine Nation Ukraine people Ukraine
economy and the very self of Ukrainian
identity this world already having
irreversible consequences not only for
Ukraine but also for whole European
continent and the world
loss of life destroyed to cities
destroyed infrastructure environmental
and ecosystem destruction nuclear
aggression threats this war crime
actions of terroristic state of Russian
are putting in danger in the life itself
illegal temporary occupation of
Ukraine's territories also undermines
the reliability of reporting data and
all consequent unfcc reports Ukraine
continuously raising its concerns
over the reliability of reporting data
under unfcc and stress the need
to address the robotness of reporting
and transparency as a matter of crucial
importance on cop 27 agenda item 4
Ukraine welcomed the proposal by the
chair to defer the consideration of the
agenda item to the next session this war
is undermining the Integrity of the
convention and Paris agreement this war
is limiting our rights for sustainable
development and evolves availability
to address climate change challenges
while undermining the basis principles
of international cooperation we will
need to address it wants the peace the
territorial Integrity of Ukraine is
distorted I thank you chair
I thank the secrets representative of
Ukraine
I call them the representative of
Belarus
may I ask the secretary to provide a
microphone for the representatives of
Belarus
foreign
want to take the floor
it does not seem to be the case
with any other delegation like to take
the floor at this time
since there seems to be none I now
invite the cop to consider agenda item
2G
dates and venues for future sessions
in accordance with the practice of
rotation among Regional groups the Asia
Pacific States would host cop 28.
the Eastern European States would host
cop 29 and the Latin American and
Caribbean States would host cop 30.
the Asian Pacific States have nominated
the United Arab Emirates to host and
serve as president of Corp 28.
early identification of a host country
minimizes logistical and financial risks
I would therefore encourage the Eastern
European States and the Latin American
Caribbean states to accelerate their
consultations and propose a host for cop
29 and cop 30 respectively at the
earliest possible time
the cop is also invited to agree on the
dates for the sessional periods in
2025
to be recommended by the subsidiary body
I propose that a senior member of my
delegation conduct consultations on my
behalf with the relevant Regional groups
with a view to proposing a draft
decision on this matter for adoption by
The Hope cop
if I hear no objections
it's so decided
foreign
the conference to consider agenda item
seven Warsaw International mechanisms
for loss and damage associated with
climate change impacts
the mechanism and its executive
committee were established by the cop at
its 19th session
the Paris agreement article 8 paragraph
2 provides that the mechanisms shall be
subject to the authority and guidance of
the conference of the parties serving as
the meeting of the parties to the Paris
agreement
cop 24 25 and 26 were invited to
consider the matter of cop authority
over the guidance
to the Wim including its executive
committee
cop 26 noted that consideration related
to the Wim governance will continue at
cop 27.
on the matter of the governance of the
Wim I will appoint a senior member of my
delegation to undertake consultations on
the cops authority over and guidance to
the Wom
hearing no objections it is so decided
I would now invite the cop to consider
agenda item 8 matters relating to
finance including sub items a to f
before I move to the agenda sub items I
would like to draw your attention to
document F Triple C slash CP slash 2022
slash one slash add 2 which includes the
revised list of agenda agenda to be
considered under these agenda sub items
for sub item 8 a long-term climate
Finance cop 26 requested the standing
committee on finance to prepare a report
in 2022 on progress towards achieving
the goal of mobilizing jointly
US Dollars 100 billion per year to
address the needs of developing
countries in the context of meaningful
mitigation actions and transparency on
implementation taking into account the
climate Finance delivery plan and other
relevant reports
cop 26 also requested this SCF to
continue its work on the definitions of
climate finance and to undertake further
work on mapping the available
information relevant to Article 2
paragraph 1C of the Paris agreement
including its reference to article line
thereof
we would like to thank the co-chairs of
the
SCF Mrs wolinski from Australia Austria
and Mr fakir from South Africa for
leadership and work this year
the cop is invited to consider the
report on the progress towards achieving
the goal of mobilizing
jointly 100 billion US dollars per year
work conducted on mapping information
relevant to Article 2 paragraph 1C of
the Paris agreement and the input on
definitions of climate Finance
report on progress towards achieving the
goal of mobilizing jointly 100 billion
US dollars per year to address the needs
of developing countries in the context
of meaningful mitigation action and
transparency on implementation is
available on the UNF Triple C website
regarding sub item 8B matters relating
to the standing committee on finance
Corp 26 requested the committee to
organize the second part of the standing
committee on finance Forum on finance
for nature-based Solutions into 2022 and
to report to cop27 on progress in
implementing the SCF work plan for 2022
cop 26 initiated but could not conclude
consideration of the review of the
functions of the SCF discussions will
therefore continue
ad cop 27.
cop 26 also requested the SCF to
continue its work on definitions of
climate finance and to undertake further
work on mapping the available
information relevant to Article 2
paragraph 1C of the Paris agreement
including its reference to article 9
thereof
the cop is invited to consider a report
of the
SCF and to conduct the review of the
functions of the committee
regarding sub item 8C report of the
green climate fund to the conference of
the parties and the guidance to the
green climate fund
the cop is invited to provide guidance
to the GCF on policies program
priorities and eligible eligible
criteria taking into account
the annual report of the GCF
the draft guidance to the operating
entities of the financial mechanism
proposed by the Koch facilitators to the
standing committee on finance and
compilation and Analysis of submissions
received on the draft guidance outlined
in the 2022 report of the SCF and the
annual report on the operation of the
Nama registry
I would like to thank
Mr donnellier from France
and
ramaru from South Africa for their
leadership as co-chairs of the GCF board
and the members of the board for their
hard work
for sub item 8D report for the Global
Environmental facility to the conference
of the parties and guidance to the
Global Environmental facility the Corp
will be invited to provide guidance to
the gef on policy program choreographies
and eligibility eligibility criteria
taking into consideration
the annual report of the gef the draft
guidance to the operating entities of
the financial mechanism proposed by the
co-facilitators
to the standing committee on finance and
compilation and Analysis of submissions
received on the draft guidance outlined
in the 2022 report of the SCF and the
annual report on the operation of the
Nama registry
I would like to thank the chairperson of
the gef Mr Carlos Rodriguez and the gef
Secretariat for the work undertaken by
the gef
for sub item 8 e seventh review of the
financial mechanism the cop is invited
to agree on the guidelines for the
seventh review of the financial
mechanism taking into account the
guidelines outlined in the annex to
decision 12 CP 22.
and you may recall our understanding to
include a sub item 8f matters related to
funding Arrangements responding to loss
and damage associated with the adverse
effects of climate change including a
focus on addressing loss and damage
I would now like to outline the approach
for considering this agenda item
for sub item 8A I propose that Gertrude
olinsky from Austria and Carlos Fuller
from Belize co-chair the contact group
established for the sub item
for sub item 8B I propose that Janine
Felson from Belize and Dominic Malloy
from the United Kingdom of Great Britain
and Northern Ireland co-chair the
contact group established for the sub
item
for sub item 8C and D I propose that
Toro sigio from Japan and Richard
moyangi from Tanzania co-chair contact
groups established for each sub-item
for sub item 8e I propose that Ricardo
Marshall from Barbados and Kelly sharp
from Canada co-chair the contact group
established for the sub item
for sub item 8f I propose that Julio
Coronado from Chile and Ursula Fuentes
from Germany co-facilitated the informal
consultations established for this
sub-item
hearing no objections
to the previous it is so decided
I would now invite the cop to consider
agenda item 17 administrative financial
and institutional matters sub item C
decision making in the UNF Triple C
process
at cop 26 parties were unable to
conclude their consideration of this
matter and then record this with the
rules 10c and 16 of the Draft rules of
procedure being applied this matter has
been included in the provisional agenda
for cop 27.
I propose to undertake in formal
consultations on sub item 17c to be
facilitated by senior member of my
delegation
since I hear no objections it is so
decided
delegates this brings us to the end of
the first meeting of the cop
I would now like to adjourn this meeting
and open the CMP
we will meet later today after the
opening plenaries of the subsidiary
bodies for the joint plenary of the
governing and subsidiary bodies to hear
statements from groups of parties
parties and Observers
if there are no objections this meeting
of the Corp is now adjourned
[Applause]
distinguished delegates I now declare
open the 17th session of the conference
of the parties serving as the meeting of
the parties to the Kyoto Protocol
the meeting is now convened
we will now proceed with a work under
agenda item 2 organizational matters
I invite the conference to consider sub
item 2A of the provisional agenda
adoption of the agenda
I propose that the agenda be adopted as
contained in document F Triple C slash
KP C MP 2022-1
hearing no objections it is so decided
since there are no parties who have
wished to take the floor excellencies
delegates I take
let me proceed with our work
distinguished delegates and now invite
the conference to consider sub item 2C
organization of work including for the
sessions of the subsidiary bodies
I would like to propose that the
CMP differs to its 18th session the
consideration of sub item A and B of
item four
reporting from the review of parties
included in Annex One National
Communications and annual compilations
and accounting report for the second
commit commitment period for nxb parties
under the CO2 protocol from 2019 and
2020 2021 and 2022.
on the following items the CMP will take
appropriate action on the basis of
recommendations from the subsidiary
bodies
sub Item B of item seven matters related
to the adoption adapt adaptation fund
fourth review of the adaptation fund
item 8 capacity building under the Kyoto
Protocol
item 9 report of a forum on the impact
of the implementation of response
measures item 12 administrative
financial and institutional matters
these items can be considered under
existing items on the agendas of the
respective subsidiary body and that body
May develop draft decisions or
conclusions for consideration by the CMP
as appropriate
on sub agenda item 4C date of completion
of the expert review process under
article 8 of the Kyoto Protocol for the
second
commitment period you may recall that
cmp16 had referred this matter to the
subsidiary body and it's at its 56th
session the subsidiary body concluded
its work and recommended a draft CMP
decision the CMP will consider this
draft for adoption at its first
closing plenary
during the cop plenary I presented
proposals for the organization of work
as all parties to the protocol are also
parties of the convention I propose that
the CMP follows the same approach as the
cop the content of the overarching CMP
decision decision one slash CMP
17 will be addressed in the same
informal consultations as those for
Decision One slash cep 27.
during the second week of the conference
I will reconvene the CMP to consider the
decisions and conclusions for adoptions
hearing no objections it is so decided
I now invite the
I give the four to the distinguished
representative of Ukraine
thank you chair Mr English delegates
climate change is a global challenge
that requires devotion and collaboration
between countries Nations and people the
nfcc process is our unique instrument of
such International cooperation on
jointly painting climate change for over
eight years and last eight months
Ukraine is fighting another War Ukraine
is facing unprecedented unprecedented
full-scale War launched by terroristic
state of Russia against Ukraine this
immoral war in the heart of people
Europe
is the war against the Ukrainian Nation
Ukrainian people Ukrainian economy and
the Very Southwest Ukrainian Integrity
it identity this wall already having
irreversible consequences not only for
Ukraine but also for the whole Europe
and the world illegal temporary
occupation of Ukrainian territories also
undermines the reliability of reporting
data and all consequent unfcc reports
Ukraine
reiterates its raising concerns over
reliability of reporting data under
unfcc and stresses the need to address
their robotness
as a matter of crucial importance on CMP
agenda item 4 sub items A and B Ukraine
welcomes the proposal by the chair to
defer his consideration to the next
session I thank you chair
I think the distinguished representative
of Ukraine
no other delegations wish to take the
floor I now invite the CMP to consider
agenda item five matters related to the
clean development mechanism
parties may wish to refer to the annual
report of the CDM executive board has
contained and document F Triple C slash
KP CMP 2002 7.
since the publication of the annual
report the executive board methan Sharma
Sheikh last week and the meeting report
is available on the CDM web pages of the
UNF Triple C website
I would like to thank the chair of the
Executive Board of the CDM for 2022
Omar alak of Jamaica for his leadership
and the members and Alternate members of
the board for their hard work
I propose to establish a contract group
to consider this item
to be co-chaired by
Kazu he is he
katasu from Japan and Alec
from Zambia
if there are no objections
it is so decided
election of members and alternative
members of the CDM executive board will
be conducted during the closing CMP
plenary
I now invite the CMP to consider agenda
item six matters related to Joint
implementation
the CMP is invited to consider the
annual report of the joint
implementations
Subs supervisory committee contained and
document F Triple C slash KP slash CMP
slash
20226 I would like to thank the chair of
the joint implementation
supervisory committee for 2022 Jacob
lens from Austria for his leadership and
the members of the alternate members of
the GIS C for their hard work
dear colleagues I would propose that the
CMP takes note of the annual report of
the gisc
I would also propose that the CMP
expressed its appreciation to the gis SC
for its prudent management of resources
during the year
I will take up the joint implementation
supervisory committees recommendations
although this continuation of its
activities under presidency
consultations
if there are no objections
so decided
elections of members and alternative
members of the GI
SC may be conducted during the closing
CMP plenary
I now invite the CMP to consider agenda
item 7A matters relating to the
adaptation fund report of the adaptation
fund board
parties may wish to refer to the annual
report of the adaptation fund board
contained and document F Triple C slash
KP CMP slash
2022-4 F Triple C
slash PA slash CMA slash
2022-3 and it's addendum I would like to
thank the chair of the adaptation fund
board Albert taufiq from Saudi Arabia
and the members of the alternate members
of the board for their hard work
I propose to establish a contact group
to consider this item be co-chaired by
Eva Schroeder from the Netherlands and
Diane black line from Antigua and
Barbados
hearing no objections
I give the floor to the DRC
ie Mexico president
elections is
adaptations
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
I thank the distinguished representative
of the DRC and they take this
opportunity to thank the DRC for having
also the pre-cop which has certainly
contributed to the smooth work that we
are now undertaken
I see no other delegations which wish to
take the floor at this time
we turn to election of members and
alternative members of the other
adaptation fund board
will be conducted during the closing CMP
plenary
the first Contact group on this item
will be held today at 17 30 in MR16
please check the CCTV and the daily
program for the latest information
and now I invite the CMP to consider
agenda item 10 report of the compliance
committee parties may wish to refer to
report of the compliance committee
contained and document F Triple C slash
KP CMP slash 2022 slash two
I would like to thank the chairpersons
of the committee
koniko shimada
Paulette Milo Lisa Benjamin and Carolina
antonena for the leadership and the
members and alternative members for
their hard work
I propose to convene the informal
consultations to consider this item to
be facilitated by Miss conzanga from
Bhutan
there are no objections it is so decided
I would like to thank the facilitators
for accepting this role please consult
the city CCTV and daily program for
confirmation and details on the room
number
I now invite the CMP to consider agenda
item 11. reports on the high-level
ministerial Roundtable on increased
ambition of Kyoto Protocol commitments
consultations during cmp-16 on this
matter revealed that views remain
Divergent on whether further work is
needed under this agenda item
I propose to undertake consultations to
be facilitated by Mr AMR Osama Abdel
Aziz of my delegation
hearing no objections it is so decided
delegations
distinguished delegates this brings us
to the end of our first meeting of the
CM CMP I would now like to adjourn this
meeting and open the CMA
we will meet later today after the
opening plenaries of the subsidiary
bodies for the joint plenary meeting of
the governing and subsidiary bodies to
hear statements from groups of parties
parties and Observers
the meeting of the CMP
is now adjourned
[Applause]
distinguished delegates and now declare
open the fourth session of the
conference of the parties serving as the
meeting of the parties to the Paris
agreement
the meeting is thereby open
we will now proceed with a work under
agenda item 2 organizational matters
I invite the conference to consider sub
item 2A of the provisional agenda
adoption of the agenda
I invite parties to turn to document F
Triple C P a slash CMA
2022 1 slash add four which contains the
supplementary provisional agenda
with the understandings
that I previously outlined in the first
plenary meeting of the cop
I propose that the supplementary
provisional agenda is contained in
document F Triple C P a slash CMA
2022-1 add 4 be adopted
being no objections it is so decided
proceeding with our work I now invite
the conference to consider sub item to
see organization of work including the
sessions of the subsidiary bodies
on the following items the CMA will take
appropriate action on the basis of
recommendations from the relevant
subsidiary body
item 4 matters relating to the work
program for urgently scaling up
mitigation ambition and implementation
referred to in paragraph 27 of decision
one slash CMA
3.
sub Item B of item five reporting and
review pursuant to Article 13 of the
Paris agreement options for conclu
conducting reviews on a voluntary basis
of information reported pursuant to
chapter 4 of the annex to decision 18's
last CMA one and respective training
courses needed to facilitate these
voluntary reviews
sub item a of a item six matters
relating to adaptation report of the
adaptation committee
sub item C of item six matters relating
to adaptation Glasgow Sharma Sheikh work
program on the global goal on adaptation
referred to in decision seven slash cma3
item 7 Warsaw International mechanism
for loss and damage associated with
climate change impacts
sub items A and B of item 9 development
and transfer of Technologies and
implementation of the technology
mechanism
item 10 capacity building under the
Paris agreement
item 11 matters related to the least
developed countries
item 12 report of the Forum on the
impact of implementation of response
measures
item 13 guidance on Cooperative
approaches referred to in article 6
paragraph 2 of the Paris agreement
item 15 work program under the framework
for non-market approaches referred to in
article 6 paragraph 8 of the Paris
agreement
sub item A and B of item 17
administrative financial and
institutional matters
these items are already on the agendas
of the respective subsidiary body and
that body May develop draft decisions or
conclusions for consideration by the CMA
as appropriate
in addition I propose to refer the
following matters to the relevant
subsidiary body
under agenda item 5 reporting and review
pursuant to Article 13 of the Paris
agreement
I propose to refer the consideration of
sub item 5A provision of Financial and
Technical Support to developing
countries parties for reporting and
capacity building to the subsidiary body
under items six matters relating to
adaptation I propose to refer the
consideration of sub Item B review of
progress Effectiveness and performance
of the
adaptation committee to the substance
and the SBI
during the cop plenary I presented
proposals for the organization of work
as all parties to the agreement are also
parties to the convention I propose that
the CMA follows the same approach as the
cop the content of the overarching CMA
decision decision one slash CMA 4 will
be addressed in the same informal
consultations as those for Decision One
CP 27.
distinguished delegates I would like to
take this opportunity to draw parties as
tensions to documents F Triple C slash
PA CMA slash 2022 slash 4 and CF and F
Triple C slash PA CMA slash 2022-8
these synthesis reports respond to the
requests in paragraph 30 of decision
once last cma3 with a Secretariat was
requested to annually update the
synthesis reports on nationally
determined contributions under the Paris
agreement referred to in decision one
slash cma2 paragraph 10 to be made
available to the CMA at each of its
sessions as well as paragraph 34 of the
same decision one cma3 where the
Secretariat was requested to prepare a
synthesis report on long-term low
greenhouse gas emission development
strategies referred to in article 4
paragraph 19 of the Paris agreement to
be made available at cma4
the synthesis reports which are
available on the UNF Triple C's website
provide an overview of where parties
stand in terms of the ambition and
actions outlined in their nationally
determined contributions and long-term
low greenhouse gas emission development
strategies and they can serve as useful
inputs to your deliberations here in
Sharma Sheikh
both reports highlight the urgent need
for immediate and scaled up
implementation of climate action
during the second week of the conference
we will reconvene the CMA to consider
the decisions and conclusions for
adoption
since there are no objections we will
proceed on this base basis it is so
decided
are now invite the CMA to consider
agenda item 8 matters relating to
finance including sub item a to f
before I move to the agenda sub items I
would like to draw your attention to
document after posi slash PA CMA
2022 1 add 4 which includes the revised
list of agendas to be considered under
these agenda sub items I would like to
introduce all the sub items
slash seven the synthesis of views
regarding
way to achieve Article 2 paragraph 1C of
the Paris agreement the input on
definitions of climate finance and other
outcomes of the scf's work and to take
any action it deems appropriate the CMA
is also invited to continue its
consideration of the review of the
functions of the SCF as part of the
review referred to in decision 11 CP 25.
regarding sub item 8B guidance to the
green climate fund the CMA is invited to
provide guidance to the GCF on policies
program priorities and eligibility
criteria related to the Paris agreement
for transmission by the cop
regarding sub item 8C guidance to the
Global Environmental facility the CMA is
invited to provide guidance to the gef
on policy program priorities and it is a
legibility
criteria related to the Paris agreement
for transmission to the cop
regarding sub item Ada matters related
to adaptation fund the CMA is invited to
take any action that deems appropriate
on matters relating to the adaptation
fund and considering the outcomes of the
report review of the adaptation fund as
referred in decision Force lessee MP 16
paragraph 7.
regarding sub item 8e new Collective
qualified goal on climate Finance the
CMA is invited to take stock of the
progress made and providing further
guidance on the ad hoc work program
taking into consideration the annual
report of the co-chairs of the ad hoc
working program and the summary of the
deliberations at the high-level
ministerial dialogue taking place on not
I would like to thank Frederica fercano
from Italy and kishan Kamar Singh from
Trinidad and Tobago for their leadership
as co-chairs of ad hoc work program and
for their work conducted over the year
regarding sub item 8f matters relating
to funding Arrangements responding to
loss and damage associated with the
adverse effects of climate change
including a focus on addressing loss and
damage the CMA is invited to initiate
its consideration of this matter
I would now like to outline the approach
for considering these agenda sub-items
consideration of sub item 8A will be
undertaken and the contact group
established established for cop agenda
sub item 8A co-chaired by Dominic Malloy
from the United Kingdom
and Janine Felson from Belize
consideration of sub item 8B and c will
be undertaken by the contact group
established from the cop agenda sub item
8 B and C and co-chaired by true segur
from Japan and Richard
Maya Rooney from Tanzania
consideration of sub item ad will be
undertaken in the content group
established for the CMP agenda item 7A
co-chaired by Diane
Blake Lane from Antigua and Barbados
Barbados and ever Schroeder from the
Netherlands for sub item 8e I propose
that George Borstein from Norway and
Zahir fakir from South Africa co-chair
the contact group established for the
sub item
consideration of sub item 8f will be
undertaken in the contact group
established for the cup agenda item 8f
co-chaired by Julio
cordano from Chile and Ursula Fuentes
from Germany
I hear no objections to the above it is
so decided
[Applause]
the first Contact group for sub item ad
will be held today at 7 17 45 in MR16
please check the CCTV and daily program
for the latest schedule
I now invite the conference to consider
item 14 rules modalities and procedures
for the mechanisms established by
article 6 paragraph 4 of the Paris
agreement
the CMA is invited to consider the
annual report of the subsidiary body for
the mechanism established by article 6
paragraph 4 of the Paris agreement as
contained in document F Triple C P a
slash CMA 2022-6
since the publication of the annual
report the
supervisory body met here in Sharma
Sheikh and worked late into last night
with the aim of completing work mandated
for the cma4 that work is captured in
the addendum to the annual report and
will be published and distributed to
parties in due course
I would like to thank the chair and vice
chair of the supervisory body for 2022
Christine gray and
Pietro
dombrovnik for their leadership and the
members and alternative members of the
Body for their hard work
in addition
under this agenda item the CMA will
consider the
sbsta conclusions related to the article
6 paragraph four of the Paris agreement
once concluded this week
to conduct this work contact group to be
co-chaired by Kate Hancock from
Australia and Sonam
shy from Bhutan is proposed to be
established
since I hear no objections it is so
decided
I'll now invite the CMA to consider
agenda item 16 report of the committee
to facilitate implementation and promote
compliance referred to an Article 15
paragraph 2 of the Paris agreement
parties may wish to refer to the report
of the Paris agreement implementation
and compliance committee contained and
document after Posse slash PA CMA 2022-2
I would like to thank Christine vyog and
uh haseeb gohar co-chairs of the
committee for their leadership as well
as the members and Alternate members for
their hard work I propose to establish a
contact group to consider this item to
be co-chaired by kunzang from Bhutan and
Aaron Riedel from Germany
since I hear no objections it is so
decided
I would like to thank the co-chairs for
accepting this role I invite parties to
refer to the Daily program and CCTV for
information on the time and location of
the first meeting of the contact group
election of members and alternative
members of the committee will be
conducted during the closing CMA plenary
delegates this brings us to the end of
our first meeting of the CMA
we will meet later today after the
opening plenaries of these subsidiary
bodies for the joint plenary of the
governing and subsidiary bodies to hear
statements from groups of parties
parties and Observers
this meeting
I give the floor to Ireland
does Ireland wish to take the floor or
is it merely a technical glitch
it might appear to have been a technical
glitch
since there are no parties which wish to
take to the floor at this time I declare
the meeting of the CMA is now adjourned
[Applause]
um
all right
as a point of information
please note that the substance will open
at 3 pm in this room
for those who
all of those who will be in attendance I
thank you